you know the principles that I turn to
as a
leader in practice I would say always
innovate always accelerate always
collaborate and always communicate I
mean think about covid I didn't wait for
other cities to figure it out or even
bother whether it was my jurisdiction to
set up testing centers be the first city
to close things down the first to
mandate masks the first to erase the
racial Gap with African-American deaths
the first to test people without
symptoms I just did it so it was
innovate and accelerate but I couldn't
have done that if I hadn't spent seven
years collaborating I've met with 87
other Mayors in my region quarterly that
I convened for seven years so they trust
me they know me I listen to them I
Elevate their voices so collaboration is
really important and then for 74 times
I've been before my public communicating
hard truths in the middle of a crisis I
got sick of my own voice but I kept
doing it now it's thankfully once or
twice a week though we'll probably ramp
up given the rise right now but it was
daily for the first few months and I
think communication is everything own
your story tell your story and think
like an author you're a narrator once
you get to be at the highest levels of
leadership and then the personal things
that I would say is be humble but be
Fearless learn to listen it's more
important than learning how to speak and
then I'll come back to what I said in
the previous question lead with love
that really is you know my my motto my
team makes fun of me until they start to
adopt it and they see that all those
things as a good leader mean nothing if
you're not leading from a moral place of
love